Next question is about Andrew Yang.
Hey David, when will Andrew Yang entered the
top three Democratic primary candidates in
the polling?
So I'm going to assume that this is a serious
question because the person who sent it has
been emailing me about Andrew Yang in a perfectly
reasonable and serious manner for a year and
they genuinely seem to be fans and supporters
of Andrew Yang.
I'm not going to assume it's a trolling question,
but here's the deal.
Andrew Yang is not going to enter the top
three in 2020 democratic polling and that's
okay.
All right.
He's done way more than many people expected.
He has introduced some interesting ideas into
the 2020 democratic primary discussion.
Now I know a lot of people will say, David,
stop it.
Andrew has said his goal is not pull 3% his
goal is to be president of the United States.
That's great.
That should be everyone's goal.
Who's running for president?
I wish everybody was genuinely running because
they believe that they are going to be president
of the United States.
I have no problem with Andrew and personally.
I like him.
I've interviewed him multiple times.
I see him as sincere.
I see him as genuine.
I don't see him as some kind of right Libertarian
Trojan horse.
As some people have pointed out, he has policy
ideas.
Some are better than others.
There are problems with some of his policy
ideas and that's all as we would expect with
any candidate, but he's not going to pull
in the top three and it's not because I don't
believe in him.
Okay.
Andrew Yang was in sixth place heading into
the third debate last night behind Biden,
Bernie, Warren Harris and Buddha judge.
It is already a huge accomplishment that he's
ahead of all sorts of actual elected officials
and political insiders.
He's ahead of Beto and Cory booker and Tulsi
Gabbert and numerous other members of Congress
and more establishment people who had higher
name recognition at the beginning of this
campaign.
Now maybe I'll be eating my hat next week
if new posts, debate polling shows Andrew
Yang in third place, but between Biden and
Bernie and Warren, that's roughly two thirds
of the Democratic primary electorate already.
If you look at their second choices, I don't
see a mathematical path for Andrew Yang to
break the top three.
Even if everyone other than Biden, Bernie
and Warren drops out and Andrew Yang gets
a full 50% of all of that support of all those
other people.
That's 11 points.
It's still not enough to break into third
place and that's not even accounting for the
reality that the support of some of those
other candidates would go to Bernie Biden
and Warren making it even more difficult for
Andrew Yang to catch up so he's not going
to enter the top three in this election.
That doesn't mean he can't have an impact.
It doesn't mean he's a bad person.
It doesn't mean he's running a bad campaign.
He has ideas, some of which are good and some
of which are less good like any candidate
and that's all great.
But if people are genuinely waiting for the
day in which we say Andrew Yang has pulled
into second place, I don't see it happening.
If you disagree with me, give me the mathematical
path that Andrew Yang has, not just, he's
gonna just crush it, uh, between now and election
day and the first primaries and he'll be in
second or third place before you know it.
I just don't see it convinced me that I'm
wrong.